Tyra: LAST SEASON ON "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL"...
ADRIANNE CURRY WENT FROM
WAITRESSING IN JOLIET,
ILLINOIS, TO TOP MODEL,
NOW IN DEMAND BY REVLON,
TOP MAGAZINES AND
DESIGNERS.
NOW WE'VE DISCOVERED A
NEW GROUP OF UNKNOWNS,
LIKE CALIFORNIA GIRL HEATHER,
AWAY FROM HOME
FOR THE FIRST TIME,
PERSIAN BEAUTY SARA WHO FEARS
HER FATHER'S REACTION TO
HER SECRET DREAM OF MODELING,
JENASCIA, A SASSY WAITRESS,
WHO AT 5'7" SEES
HERSELF AS THE NEXT KATE MOSS.
LAST WEEK THE GIRLS LEARNED
HOW TO WORK THE RUNWAY.
12heather, the judges
AND CATIE WALKED
AWAY WITH THE PRIZE.
YOANNA ACCUSED CAMILLE OF
GOSSIPING BEHIND HER BACK.
Camille: WHAT ARE YOU HEARING?
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING?
Yoanna: DON'T START.
DON'T START.
I DON'T TRUST YOU.
Tyra: AND SHANDI
STRUGGLED TO KEEP UP.
Janice: ARE YOU KIDDING
ME WITH THAT WALK?
Tyra: BUT IT WAS
BETHANY WHO WAS SENT HOME.
TEN GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE
ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
Shandi: THE LAST ELIMINATION,
I SERIOUSLY THOUGHT
IT WAS GONNA BE ME.
I KEEP THINKING
ABOUT HOW BAD MY WALK WAS.
TO COMPETE AGAINST THESE
OTHER GIRLS, I NEED TO BE
ONE STEP ABOVE IT.
I HAVE NO EXCUSES.
IF I TRULY WANT THIS, I'M
GONNA NEED TO DO BETTER.
I NEED TO TRY HARDER.
Mercedes: MY INITIAL REACTION
ABOUT SHANDI IS THAT SHE IS
THIS NERDY KINDA DORK
KINDA GIRL WITH
THE GLASSES.
Sara: I'VE SEEN A LOT OF
UNATTRACTIVE MODELS
AND A LOT OF GIRLS THAT ARE
USED IN MAGAZINES.
I'M JUST LIKE, WHY THE HELL DID
THEY PUT THESE GIRLS
IN THIS MAGAZINE?
BUT IT'S BECAUSE IT
DRAWS PEOPLE TO THEM.
Women: (speaking indistinctly)
Catie: SEE IF
I CAN DO THIS.
ALL RIGHT, AND SHUFFLE...
(laughing)
Xiomara: CATIE'S BEHAVIOR CAN BE
DEFINITELY
ATTENTION-SEEKING.
JUST A LITTLE,
BUT I LOVE HER.
Catie: (laughing)
Heather: WHILE
EVERYONE'S TRYING TO GET
THE SPOTLIGHT HERE, THEY'RE
NOT VERY SOCIABLE WITH ME,
EVEN THOUGH
I'M VERY SOCIABLE.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHY THAT IS.
BUT IN THE HOUSE,
YOU DO NEED SOMEONE.
YOU CAN'T JUST
GO THROUGH LIFE
NOT TALKING TO ANYONE.
Heather's mother: Hello.
Heather: MOM.
Heather's mother: Yeah.
Are you okay?
Heather: I FEEL LIKE
COMING HOME.
Heather's mother: So it's not
all that fun, huh?
Heather: NO. IT'S JUST,
LIKE, THESE PEOPLE HERE--
THEY HAVE THEIR LITTLE CLIQUES.
WHEN I WANNA TALK OR SOMETHING,
THEY TRY TO, LIKE,
NOT PAY ATTENTION TO ME.
IT'S JUST ME.
Heather's mother: It'll
be all right, Heather.
Just do the best that
you can possibly do.
Heather: I LOVE YOU SO MUCH.
Heather's mother: I love you,
Heather.
Heather: I'M ONLY 18 YEARS OLD,
AND I'VE NEVER
BEEN AWAY FROM HOME.
IT'S SAD, ESPECIALLY ME, 'CAUSE
MY MOM'S MY BEST FRIEND,
YOU KNOW?
Yoanna: GUYS,
THERE'S TYRA MAIL.
Heather: "IF YOU
THINK YOU'RE FINE,
IF YOU THINK YOU'RE GREAT, SHOW
ME WHAT YOU'RE MADE OF
AT 45 TILL 8, WHICH IS 7:15."
Shandi: WHICH IS IN... 8
MINUTES.
Heather: GOD, I'M
GLAD I WOKE UP.
Yoanna: IT'S A SALON!
Tyra: OKAY, IT'S OBVIOUS
WHERE YOU GUYS ARE TODAY.
YOU ARE IN A HAIR SALON.
WARREN-TRICOMI.
AND I HAVE THE OWNERS.
THIS IS EDWARD TRICOMI.
AND THIS IS JOEL WARREN.
THEY ARE GOING TO TAKE YOU FROM
ORDINARY TO EXTRAORDINARY.
Catie: I REALLY FEEL LIKE I NEED
TO PINCH MYSELF
EVERY SECOND OF THE DAY.
THIS IS
A ONCE-IN-A-LIFETIME THING.
I'M NOT GONNA CARE WHAT THEY
DO WITH MY HAIR.
Tyra: I ALSO HAVE JAY MANUEL
HERE WHO, YOU KNOW,
BEATS MY FACE AND MAKES ME LOOK
LOVELY FOR MY PHOTO SHOOTS
AND PERSONAL APPEARANCES.
AND HE'S GONNA DO THE
SAME FOR YOU TODAY.
HE'S GONNA GIVE YOU
A MAKEUP LESSON,
SO THAT YOU KNOW
HOW TO DO IT YOURSELF.
Jay: AND I'LL HAVE TO BE
REALLY HONEST WITH YOU.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE NEED THE
MAKEUP POLICE HERE TODAY.
Tyra: YOU'RE ALSO GOING
TO HAVE YOUR NAILS DONE.
TOP MODELS DON'T
NEED TO HAVE TIPS.
YOU DON'T NEED
TO HAVE ACRYLICS.
AND SOME OF YOU ARE GONNA
GET YOUR TEETH WHITENED.
THIS IS NOT JUST
AN ORDINARY MAKEOVER.
I'M TAKING IT TO
THE NEXT LEVEL.
MISS CATIE, YOU ARE VERY
REMINISCENT OF TWIGGY TO ME,
SO WE ARE CHOPPING
YOUR HAIR OFF.
SARA, WE'RE GONNA
MAKE YOU BLONDE.
YOANNA, A MODERN MOHAWK.
Yoanna: OH, COOL.
Tyra: MERCEDES, WE'RE GONNA ADD
SOME EXTENSIONS TO YOUR HAIR
AND MAKE IT REALLY
BIG AND WILD
AND KIND OF ANIMALISTIC.
JENASCIA, YOU ARE 5'7".
YOUR HAIR IS TOO LONG
FOR THAT HEIGHT.
WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE YOU
FROM HERE TO...
(imitates clock ticking)
RIGHT HERE.
XIOMARA, YOUR HAIR'S
GONNA BE WAVY AND WILD.
APRIL, WE ARE GOING TO
MAKE YOUR HAIR DARKER.
AND WE'RE GONNA GIVE
YOU A BANG.
CAMILLE, CHILD, YOU'D BETTER
START TAKING OUT THEM BRAIDS
RIGHT NOW.
THE BRAIDS ARE GORGEOUS, BUT
THEY ARE NOT VERSATILE
ENOUGH FOR FASHION MODELING.
MISS SHANDI
BACK THERE.
MISS SHANDI, WITH THAT BROWN
HAIR THAT JUST LOOKS LIKE,
"I'M STOCKING THE SHELF AT
WALGREENS, "
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE
YOU A PLATINUM BLONDE.
ALSO, YOU ARE GOING TO BE
GETTING SOME CONTACTS FITTED.
AND FINALLY, HEATHER,
WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU
A LITTLE BIT MORE BLONDE.
Heather: ALL THE OTHER
GIRLS--THEY GOT
A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT LOOK,
AND IT JUST KINDA
BOTHERS ME.
Tyra: OKAY, LET'S GO!
♪♪♪
Catie: WHAT AM I DOING?
Joel: THIS IS
THE TRANSFORMATION
FROM WEST COAST TO EAST COAST.
Heather: ARE YOU SERIOUS?
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE?
Catie: I HOPE
IT'S SUPPOSED
TO BE STEAMING
LIKE THIS.
Mercedes: I'VE NEVER HAD THIS
DONE BEFORE SO I'M JUST
LEARNING HOW TO CONTROL
MY PAIN OF TOLERANCE.
Tyra: DO YOU LIKE YOUR CUT?
Yoanna: YES, I LOVE IT.
I REALLY DO.
Tyra: YEAH,
I GOT A
GLIMPSE OF IT.
IT'S VERY ROOSTER.
Yoanna: MM-HMM.
I CAN PLAY WITH IT.
I'M GONNA PLAY WITH
IT LATER ON.
Jay: NOW IN TERMS OF
CREATING A SMOKY EYE...
Yoanna: JAY MANUEL WAS SHOWING
US HOW TO APPLY MAKEUP
THE CORRECT WAY.
Jay: ALWAYS WANT TO
START WITH A COLOR
THAT TRANSITIONS OUT.
Yoanna: MY NEW LOOK
IS FANTASTIC.
I LOVE IT.
I CAN DO PEACOCK
HAIR, CLASSIC.
I COULD DO ANYTHING.
Catie: I'VE NEVER BLEACHED
MY HAIR LIKE THIS BEFORE.
AND I NEVER WANT
TO EVER, EVER,
EVER, EVER AGAIN.
Jenascia: THE HAIRCUT, THEY
SAID, WAS BECAUSE IT MAKES
ME LOOK TALLER.
YEAH, THEY PLAYED THE
TALL CARD
WITH ME AGAIN.
Mercedes: YOU DON'T
LIKE THIS?
THIS LOOKS REALLY GOOD.
Jenascia: I JUST
HATE SHORT HAIR.
Sara: I'M SICK OF THESE
BITCHES COMPLAINING
ABOUT EVERYTHING.
WE GET HAIR COLOR, CUT, AND
EVERYTHING IS BEING DONE
FOR US, AND PEOPLE ARE
STILL COMPLAINING.
Jay: I LOVE YOUR COLOR.
YOU LIKE IT?
YOU LOVE YOUR WEAVE?
Sara: YEAH, I'M LOVING IT.
MY RESULTS ARE FABULOUS.
IT'S A CHANGE.
IT'S CRAZY, BUT
I'M LIKING IT.
Shandi: THIS IS
THE COOLEST
HAIRCUT I'VE EVER HAD.
Tyra: THEY'RE TAKING OFF
THE HOOCHIE NAILS.
Camille: YES, I
SOAKED THEM OFF.
Tyra: WHAT I DO, IS
I DO BUFFING NAILS.
SEE HOW THAT,
LIKE, IT'S SHINY?
Camille: KARINA'S HANDS
IN MY HAIR FEELS SO GOOD.
TO ME, IT'S
THERAPEUTIC.
I FEEL VERY
SEXY AND YOUNGER,
AND I FEEL LIGHTER.
I REALLY LIKE IT
A LOT.
Xiomara: I LOVE IT.
I LOVE IT.
♪♪♪
Man: MAGIC MIRROR.
IT'S GOOD, RIGHT?
Shandi: REALLY GOOD.
Edward: RIGHT
NOW SHE DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S REALLY--
Catie: NO, I
DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE WHOLE CONCEPT.
HELP ME.
HELP ME
UNDERSTAND.
Yoanna: CATIE'S
OBVIOUSLY 18.
SOMETIMES SHE'LL BE A
LITTLE MORE SOPHOMORIC
THAN THE REST OF US.
Catie: I'M DEFINITELY
SCARED RIGHT NOW.
I FEEL BALD.
April: THAT'S EXACTLY HOW
I PICTURED IT.
Catie: IT WAS SO PRETTY
WHEN HE FIRST DID IT
'CAUSE IT WAS LONG.
Jenascia: CATIE JUST
COMES ACROSS
AS THIS REALLY
SWEET, INNOCENT,
I'M A LITTLE CHILD,
NURTURE ME,
COMFORT ME,"
BUT SHE TOLD ME
THAT SHE CAN CRY AT
THE DROP OF A HAT.
Catie: (crying)
I LOOK LIKE A BOY.
Tyra: RIGHT NOW,
YEAH,
IT'S A LITTLE
OLIVER TWIST.
BUT WHEN THEY STYLE IT AND YOU
GET YOUR MAKEUP DONE,
IT'S GONNA BE
SO PRETTY.
YOU GOTTA TRUST
ME, OKAY?
Catie: OKAY.
Tyra: BUT IT'S OKAY TO
CRY 'CAUSE IT'S DIFFERENT.
IT'S A CHANGE,
BUT YOU'RE NOT
GONNA LOOK LIKE A
BOY, GIRL.
YOU GOT SOME TITTIES.
YOU GOT BOOTY.
YOU'RE GONNA WORK IT OUT.
Heather: I'M JUST KINDA WORRIED
ABOUT MY HAIR
'CAUSE I DIDN'T
HAVE ANY KIND
OF CHANGE,
THAT IN THE END,
THEY MIGHT LOOK AT
ME, AND SAY,
"HEY, YOU HAVEN'T
HAD ANY KIND
OF CHANGE.
CAN YOU CHANGE?"
Man: THESE ARE FRESHLOOK
LENSES
FOR ASTIGMATISM.
HOW'D YOU DO?
Shandi: I CAN SEE.
April: WOW.
I LOVE THE COLOR.
I LOVE EVERYTHING.
Jay: TO TAKE THIS TO A SMOKY
EYE, TAKE A LITTLE
BLACK SHADOW AND
THEN THE LINER
AND THEN MASCARA.
April: I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT MAKEUP.
I BOUGHT MY FIRST TUBE
OF MASCARA YESTERDAY.
WOW.
BUT AS SOON
AS SHE DID
THE FIRST SNIP,
I KNEW IT WAS PERFECT BECAUSE
MY CHEEKBONES POPPED OUT.
Jay: NOW YOU SEE HOW I
CAN STILL SEE THE REMNANTS
OF A LITTLE LINE?
CAN YOU TELL?
Xiomara: YES. YES. SORRY.
Jay: DON'T DO THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
Xiomara: I'M FROM JERSEY.
I'M SORRY.
Jay: YOU DON'T HAVE TO
APOLOGIZE, BUT NOW IT SHOWS.
Xiomara: MY NEW LOOK IS VERY
GIRLY, VERY SEXY.
I HAVE TO WORK ON
BEING SEXY 'CAUSE I'M NOT.
Tyra: OH, IT'S PRETTY!
IT'S LIGHT
AND PRETTY.
Mercedes: I LIKE MY LOOK.
IT'S VIBRANT.
IT'S SEXY.
IT'S EDGY.
WE WENT THROUGH
A LOT TODAY,
SOME TEARS,
SOME FRUSTRATION.
SOME PEOPLE I WANTED
TO SHOOT IN THE HEAD.
Xiomara: SHANDI,
YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
Camille: OH, MY GOD.
Shandi: EVERYTHING
JUST LOOKS SO GOOD.
EVERYTHING'S
COME TOGETHER.
AND I FEEL SO PRETTY
RIGHT NOW.
Catie: (crying)
♪♪♪
Catie: YOU'RE GONNA BE
SHOCKED WHEN I COME HOME.
Catie's boyfriend: Why?
Catie: BECAUSE.
Catie's boyfriend:
Please don't tell me
you cut your hair.
Is it short,
like boy short?
Catie, you
don't have to cry.
They cut your hair.
If it has to be done
to further your career...
Catie: I KNOW.
Catie's boyfriend: I'm sure
it looks good.
Are you getting
compliments on it?
Catie: YEAH.
I GUESS I JUST HAVE TO
GET USED TO CHANGE
AND
REINVENTING MYSELF A LOT
BECAUSE MODELS DO THAT,
LIKE, EVERY MONTH.
Yoanna: IS THAT ALL
YOUR LUNCH?
THAT'S ALL YOU'RE EATING?
Heather: (speaks indistinctly)
Yoanna: YOU'RE GONNA GET SICK
IF YOU EAT LIKE THAT.
Heather: UNH-UNH.
Yoanna: HAVE SOME
MORE CHICKEN.
IT'S GOOD.
I MARINATED IT.
Heather: YOANNA,
I THINK,
IS DIFFERENT
FROM EVERYONE ELSE.
I FEEL LIKE SHE'S THE ONLY
PERSON THAT ACTUALLY CARES.
Yoanna: HERE.
EAT MORE.
Catie: IS THERE TYRA MAIL?
Xiomara: YEP.
"BE READY AT 2:00
TO BEAT YOUR FACE AND
BEAT THE CLOCK ."
BEAT YOUR FACE
AND BEAT THE TIME.
WE'RE GONNA BE TIMED
TO DO WHAT JAY TAUGHT US
IN THE SALON.
Jay: HEY, GIRLS.
YESTERDAY I SPENT A LOT OF
TIME TALKING ABOUT HOW TO CREATE
A GLAMOROUS, SMOKY EYE.
NOW TODAY WE'RE GONNA
TEST YOUR SKILLS.
LET'S LOOK AT THESE
PHOTOS I HAVE BEHIND ME.
TO MY RIGHT,
TYRA WITH NO MAKEUP.
AND TO MY LEFT,
TYRA WITH A GLAMOROUS,
SMOKY EYE.
SO YOU HAVE TO
GO FROM THIS
TO THIS, BUT
YOU HAVE 15 MINUTES
TO ACHIEVE THIS LOOK.
NOW THERE'S ONE CATCH.
Women: (groan)
Yoanna: ONE MIRROR.
Jay: YOU HAVE ONE
MIRROR, ONE SET OF BRUSHES,
ONE MAKEUP PALETTE, TEN PAIRS OF
EYELASHES, THOUGH,
AND TEN SPONGES.
NOW THIS IS A VERY
REALISTIC SITUATION.
IF YOU WALK IN LAST MINUTE
TO A FASHION SHOW,
THE MAKEUP ARTISTS
ARE OCCUPIED.
YOU HAVE TO FIGHT OVER ONE
LITTLE PALETTE THAT'S LEFT OUT
FOR THOSE LAST MINUTE
TOP MODEL DIVA ARRIVALS.
Jenascia: NOT BEING ABLE
TO SEE IN THE MIRROR,
THAT'S GONNA BE A PROBLEM.
HAVING TO SHARE,
Jay: WHOEVER CAN GET
TO THAT THE CLOSEST
IN THE ALLOTTED TIME,
WINS THE CHALLENGE.
THE WINNER RECEIVES TONIGHT
A DINNER AT THE LOFT
WITH THREE
MYSTERY GUESTS.
AND THE TWIST TO THIS
IS THE LOSER ROOMMATES
HAVE TO SHOP, PREPARE AND
SERVE THE DINNER, OKAY?
NOW TO JUDGE THIS
TEST WITH ME,
I HAVE SEPHORA'S VERY
OWN BEAUTY EDITOR--
MY FRIEND JULIE REDFERN.
HEY, HOW ARE YOU?
Julie: GOOD.
Women: HI.
Julie: IT'S A PLEASURE
TO BE HERE AND JUDGING
THIS COMPETITION.
Jay: THERE'S ONE THING I WANT
YOU GUYS TO REALLY KEEP
IN MIND.
IT'S A COMPETITION.
THIS IS NOT A SORORITY.
YOU GUYS AREN'T JUDGED ON HOW
WELL YOU GET ALONG
WITH EACH OTHER.
REMEMBER, YOU HAVE TO SHOW ME,
AND YOU HAVE TO SHOW,
MORE IMPORTANTLY, THE
JUDGES YOUR HUNGER TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Catie: WHEN JAY GAVE US ALL THE
INSTRUCTIONS, I WAS LIKE,
GAME ON.
Xiomara: IT'S FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE TRYING
TO JUMP START.
Tyra: YOANNA, BACK UP.
Xiomara: PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO
ONE-UP THE OTHER PERSON.
YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST
NOT COOL.
Jay: THREE, TWO,
ONE. GO!
Yoanna: AAH!
SURPRISE. SURPRISE.
CRUELLA DE VIL STEALS THE
MIRROR.
Xiomara: CAMILLE
HAS A HUGE ASS.
HER BUTT IS TAKING
UP THE WHOLE COUNTER SPACE.
Jenascia: OH, MY GOD.
I WAS SO PISSED OFF.
LIKE, SERIOUSLY,
I JUST WANTED
TO STOP AND SCREAM.
Camille: I'M
NOT HERE
TO BE
FRIENDS WITH ANYONE.
YOU WANNA BE FRIENDS,
BE FRIENDS IN THE HOUSE.
Yoanna: THIS IS
THE WORST MISSION EVER.
I TRIED TO JUST STAY FOCUSED
AND NOT WORRY ABOUT CAMILLE.
I HAD TO JUST KIND OF GO TO
THE CORNER AND JUST SEE
WHAT I COULD
DO WITHOUT TRYING
TO BATTLE FOR THE MIRROR.
Heather: CAN I HAVE
THE EYE SHADOW BRUSH?
Jay: ALL RIGHT,
GUESS WHAT, GIRLS.
FIVE MINUTES LEFT.
Sara: WHO'S GOT THE SCISSORS?
EXCUSE ME.
Jenascia: THIS SUCKS ASS.
Heather: I GOT MY FINGER
CUT, YOU GUYS.
Jay: GIRLS, YOU GOT 60 SECONDS.
Shandi: REALLY HOT
LIGHT RIGHT HERE.
I'M BURNING MY ARM OFF.
I KEEP GETTING SHOVED INTO THE
LIGHTS ON THE TABLE
THAT ARE, LIKE,
EXTREMELY HOT.
Jay: TEN SECONDS.
NINE, EIGHT, SEVEN, SIX...
Shandi: I'M JUST, LIKE, I'M HOT.
I'M HOT.
I JUST KEEP
THINKING,
I'M HOT. I'M HOT.
Jay: TWO,
ONE. STOP.
PUT EVERYTHING DOWN.
I'M GONNA TAKE
A WALK DOWN
AND LOOK AT YOU ALL
UP CLOSE,
OKAY?
SO, APRIL,
FOR SOMEBODY WHO ONLY
BOUGHT HER FIRST
TUBE OF MASCARA
A DAY AGO,
YOU REALLY
IMPRESSED ME, OKAY?
SHANDI, YOU DIDN'T PUT
A FADING COLOR ON YOUR LID.
Shandi: I HAD IT ON, BUT
IT WAS, LIKE, TOO DARK.
Jay: FADED EYE LOOKS
A LITTLE MORE GLAMOROUS.
YOANNA, CLOSE YOUR
EYES AGAIN FOR ME FOR A SECOND.
SMOKY. AND YOU GOT THE
BLUSH AND THE LIP STAIN.
I THINK YOANNA'S LIPS
ARE VERY CLOSE TO TYRA'S,
ALMOST IDENTICAL.
XIOMARA, IT LOOKS
LIKE YOU HAVE
JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF BLACK HERE
AND LINER,
SO IT DOESN'T LOOK
SMOKY AT ALL.
CATIE, IT LOOKS REALLY,
REALLY GOOD.
CAMILLE, YOU DID KIND OF
THE CREASED EYE AGAIN.
I SEE THE
BLACK FOLLOWING THE CREASE
AND NOT HERE.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN, "NO"?
YEAH, THAT'S WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE.
HEATHER,
IT'S PRETTY GOOD.
THE LIPS, THOUGH--
Heather: I LIKE LIPSTICK.
Jay: YOU HAVE TO LEARN HOW TO
STAIN YOUR LIPS WITH GLOSS
AS OPPOSED TO, YOU KNOW, A VERY
LINED, FINISHED LIP.
JULIE AND I ARE GONNA JUST
TALK OVER HERE FOR A SECOND.
Julie and Jay:
(speaking indistinctly)
Jay: I FIRST HAVE TO SAY
NONE OF YOU GOT IT.
THERE'S THAT SAID.
BUT OVERALL...
I THINK YOANNA SHOULD
COME UP HERE.
Yoanna: OH, COOL.
THANKS.
Jay: SO THAT'S YOUR MENU.
YOANNA GETS TO PICK THREE
GUESTS TO JOIN HER.
AND YOU CAN CHOOSE THEM
ANY WAY YOU LIKE.
Yoanna: OKAY.
SARA, I CHOOSE YOU, AND,
XIOMARA, I CHOOSE YOU.
Jay: OH, YOU GET TO
CHOOSE ONE MORE--THREE.
Yoanna: OH, THREE.
Yoanna: I'M JUST THINKING.
APRIL, COME ON.
I'M JUST GOING THROUGH AND JUST
WONDERING WHO WOULD
I WANT TO ENJOY
THE EVENING WITH.
Jay: NO POOH-POOHING.
Heather: I THOUGHT I WAS CLOSER
TO HER THAN SOME
OF THE OTHER GIRLS,
BUT I GUESS NOT.
Jay: YOU GUYS DID
A GOOD JOB,
BUT YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO COOK THE DINNER.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
HAVE A FUN DINNER.
Catie: LET ME JUST SAY
I'M REALLY BAD.
YOU GUYS MIGHT WANT
ME TO DO THE SALAD.
Heather: IT WOULDN'T HAVE
BOTHERED ME WHEN YOANNA CHOSE
WHO SHE GOT TO PICK OUT IF
SHE DIDN'T REACH FOR ME
AND LOOK AT ME
FIRST, AND THEN TURN AWAY
AND PICK APRIL.
NO ONE'S GONNA BE
THERE FOR YOU.
THAT'S WHAT I LEARNED.
Shandi: I AM GETTING WARM.
IT IS SO HOT IN HERE.
LIKE, I START SWEATING.
I FEEL DIZZY.
Camille: SHANDI,
YOU OKAY?
Xiomara: YOU OKAY?
SHANDI!
YOU'RE NOT OKAY.
Sara: OH, MY GOD!
I LOOK OVER, AND
SHANDI'S COLLAPSED
ON THE GROUND.
Catie: HELP HER.
Jenascia: IT WAS A COMPLETE
AND TOTAL NIGHTMARE.
Xiomara: I'M SO SCARED
FOR SHANDI.
I'M SCARED.
(siren wailing)
Catie: THERE'S NOTHING
WE CAN HELP.
Yoanna: I KNEW SHANDI'S
BLOOD SUGAR WAS LOW.
I RAN TO MY BAG TO GET
HER SOME PEANUT BUTTER,
A PIECE OF CHOCOLATE OR CANDY
TO RAISE HER BLOOD SUGAR.
Shandi: IT WAS REALLY
SCARY.
I'VE NEVER
GOTTEN SO HOT
TO THE POINT OF WHERE I
WAS JUST DIZZY AND NAUSEOUS,
AND, LIKE, I
COULDN'T BREATHE.
Jenascia: YOU FEEL BETTER?
Shandi: YEAH,
MUCH BETTER.
I NEED TO MAKE THE TIME TO
GET SLEEP AND EAT AS MUCH
AS I CAN.
I PASSED OUT.
I DON'T WANT IT
TO HAPPEN AGAIN.
Heather: A GIRL PASSED
OUT TODAY.
IT'S SO STRESSFUL.
AND I'M SO SAD.
I WANT TO MODEL, BUT,
LIKE, IF THIS IS WHAT
IT TAKES, I'D RATHER
BE HAPPY,
BUT, HEY, I GOTTA GO 'CAUSE
WE'RE SERVING DINNER
RIGHT NOW, SO...
Heather's mother: I love you.
Heather: I LOVE
YOU, MOM.
Xiomara: HI, GUYS.
Yoanna: SMELLS REALLY GOOD.
I HAVE BEEN WANTING TO WIN AT
SOMETHING, AND TODAY,
IT FINALLY HAPPENED.
I'M JAZZED THAT CAMILLE'S GONNA,
YOU KNOW, COOK A MEAL
FOR ME AND MY GUESTS.
I THINK IT MIGHT DO
HER SOME GOOD.
♪♪♪
Catie: WHO IS COMING?
Sara: I DON'T KNOW.
April: I DON'T KNOW, EITHER.
A.J.: WHOO, MAN,
LOOK AT THIS PLACE.
Mike R.: HELLO.
Yoanna: HEY,
WHAT'S GOING ON?
A.J.: WHAT'S UP?
HOW'S IT GOING?
Yoanna: OUR GUESTS HAVE JUST
ARRIVED,
AND IT'S THE ADAMS FROM THE
GARDEN OF EDEN PHOTO SHOOT.
April: IT'S JUST GREAT TO HAVE
SOME KIND OF MALE
IN THE HOUSE.
Yoanna: SO HOW'D YOU GUYS GET
STARTED, LIKE, IN MODELING?
IMG JUST SIGNED YOU UP?
Mike S.: YEAH, BEEN OVER HERE
FOR, LIKE, FIVE MONTHS.
Yoanna: ARE YOU CONSTANTLY
BOOKED,
OR HOW DOES IT WORK?
I JUST WANTED TO KIND OF GET THE
INSIDE SCOOP ON IMG
AND PICK HIS BRAINS ON
HOW TO BE A SUCCESS
IF I WERE TO
WIN THAT CONTRACT.
TWIGGY, CAN I GET SOME
MORE, UM, LETTUCE?
DO YOU MIND?
Jenascia: DO WE HAVE
ANY EXTRA VEGETABLES?
Catie: HERE. PEOPLE HAVE SOME
OVER HERE THAT WE CAN JUST
CHOP UP FOR
HER OR SOMETHING.
Camille: CATIE DECIDED TO
TAKE IT UPON HERSELF
AND USE MY TOMATOES
AND USE MY LETTUCE
TO MAKE YOANNA A
SALAD WITHOUT ASKING ME.
MY DECISION, LIKE, NOT TO USE MY
VEGETABLES
'CAUSE I HAVE TO EAT TOMORROW
MYSELF, WHEN I HAVE TO PAY--
Catie: I'LL GO AND BUY YOU SOME
TONIGHT.
I'M SORRY.
Camille: WELL, YOU
SHOULDN'T
HAVE DONE THAT WITHOUT
ASKING ME FIRST, CATIE.
Catie: IT'S NOT THAT BIG
OF A DEAL, CAMILLE.
IT'S A STINKIN' TOMATO
AND, LIKE, SIX PIECES
OF LETTUCE.
GET OVER IT.
Yoanna: THAT'S RIGHT. YEAH.
Heather: YOANNA NOT PICKING ME
KIND OF BOTHERED ME, HAVING TO
SERVE HER FOOD.
DOES ANYBODY NEED ANY MORE
WATER?
WHEN I WAS
SERVING THEM,
THEY SIT THERE AND IGNORE YOU.
I MADE YOU A DINNER,
AND YOU'RE GONNA TREAT ME
WITH THIS KIND OF RESPECT?
I JUST COULDN'T
TAKE IT ANYMORE.
YOU KNOW, I TRY TO
TALK TO SOME PEOPLE,
AND THEY, LIKE,
DON'T EVEN WANT
TO LOOK AT ME WHEN
I TALK TO THEM.
THEY DON'T EVEN WANT TO,
YOU KNOW...
Catie: ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT YOU'RE SPEAKING?
Heather: ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I'M
SPEAKING.
YOU NOTICED THAT?
Catie: WE ALL GO THROUGH IT.
YOU WANT TO
START WALKING BACK?
Heather: YEAH.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I JUST
SPILLED MY GUTS.
Catie: THAT'S THE ONE
THING I LIKE ABOUT YOU.
Heather: CATIE SEEMS TO
UNDERSTAND ME, AND IT MAKES
ME HAPPY THAT SOMEONE ELSE
FEELS THE SAME WAY I DO,
THAT I'M NOT ALONE IN THIS
HOUSE.
Mercedes: WE GOT
MAIL, YOU GUYS!
Xiomara: WE GOT MAIL?
WHAT'S IT SAY?
Xiomara: "VENUSTRAPHOBIA...
Camille: "VENUSTRAPHOBIA...
Both: "THE FEAR OF BEAUTIFUL
WOMEN.
OPHIDIOPHOBIA-- THE
FEAR OF SNAKES.
ALGOPHOBIA--THE
FEAR OF PAIN.
WHAT ARE YOU AFRAID OF?
WE'LL FIND
OUT TOMORROW.
BE READY AT 7 IN
THE MORNING ."
Catie: TYRA MAIL WAS TALKING
ABOUT A PHOTO SHOOT
THAT HAD SOMETHING
TO DO WITH
PEOPLE FEARS AND PHOBIAS,
BUT I THINK FEAR
IS A COMPLETE
WASTE OF EMOTIONS AND TIME.
♪♪♪
Shandi: I WAS ABLE TO GET
A LITTLE BIT OF SLEEP
AND EAT SOMETHING,
SO I FEEL TONS BETTER.
Catie: I HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
WHEN WE GET TO
THE LOCATION.
♪♪♪
Mercedes: I MEAN, DO WE
REALLY NEED THE AMBULANCE?
Sara: WHY ARE WE IN THE
BOONDOCKS
OF THE BUILDING?
Catie: ONCE WE WALK
INTO THE BUILDING,
WE AUTOMATICALLY THINK IT HAS
SOMETHING TO DO WITH DEATH.
THERE'S, LIKE, DEAD
BIRDS EVERYWHERE,
AND PAINT'S CHIPPING OFF.
Jay: GIRLS, COME IN.
Catie: WHEN WE GOT TO THE
PLACE WHERE JAY WAS,
I SEE THESE HUGE HOLES.
VERY TERRIFIED OF THAT.
(banging)
Catie: BECAUSE MY ULTIMATE
FEAR IN LIFE IS FALLING
TO MY DEATH.
Jay: GOOD MORNING, GIRLS.
TOP MODELS TRAVEL ALL OVER THE
WORLD TO EXOTIC LOCATIONS
AND WEIRD LOCATIONS,
JUST LIKE THIS, SO TODAY WE'RE
GONNA CREATE AN ACTION
FASHION EDITORIAL,
WEARING INCREDIBLE DESIGNS
FROM LAUNDRY BY SHELLI SEGAL.
NOW THERE'S ONE
TWIST TO THIS SHOOT.
WE ARE GOING TO SUSPEND
YOU FROM THIS LEDGE
AND SHOOT YOU GUYS
HANGING OVER THIS HOLE.
Catie: I DON'T WANT TO
DO THIS.
AND I'M VERY SCARED.
I DON'T WANT TO DIE.
Jay: COOL? PSYCHED?
MEET YOU DOWNSTAIRS.
♪♪♪
Richard: I DID ONE
WHERE THEY HUNG ME OUT
OF THE HELICOPTER.
I'LL JUMP OFF ANYTHING.
Catie: I JUST WISH MY DAD WAS
HERE.
I FEEL QUEASY.
MY KNEES START
TO SHAKE,
AND I JUST WANT TO TALK
TO MY DAD.
(sobbing)
I'M SCARED OF
HEIGHTS, DAD.
I WISH YOU
COULD BE HERE.
Man: WE'RE READY TO GO.
NOW YOU CAN HOLD ON TO THE
CABLE WITH YOUR HANDS.
April:
I FEEL LIKE MARY
POPPINS. WHOO!
Richard: YEAH, YEAH!
GO WITH THE SWING.
THAT LOOKS COOL.
THAT'S COOL.
YEAH, YEAH,
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH!
APRIL--SHE HAD NO FEAR,
JUMPED RIGHT OUT
THERE.
NOT THAT FAR. RIGHT.
Shandi: WHOA.
THAT'S REALLY
FAR DOWN.
Richard: IN AND UP A LITTLE.
YEAH, THERE
YOU GO.
THAT WAY.
THERE YOU GO.
Jay: THAT'S GREAT.
Richard:
SHANDI--SHE GAVE
A TREMENDOUS
RANGE OF LOOKS, VERY SUBTLE,
BUT DIFFERENT,
SO I WAS IMPRESSED BY
WHAT SHE DID.
Sara: AAH! (laughing)
OH, MY GOD!
OH, MY GOD.
Jay: YOUR RIGHT ARM,
JUST STICK IT OUT.
I KNOW IT'S DIFFICULT. VERY
DIFFICULT, RIGHT?
SARA--SHE WAS TRYING TO
CONCENTRATE ON HER BODY
SO MUCH THAT
SHE TOTALLY FORGOT
WHAT WAS GOING ON FACIALLY.
Richard: PULL YOURSELF FORWARD.
DON'T LOOK AT ME
EVERY TIME, EITHER.
Yoanna: I WANT TO HAVE
BABIES--BE CAREFUL.
CAN I LET GO?
Man: YEAH.
Yoanna: OKAY, LETTING
GO. ALL RIGHT.
Jay: BODY LANGUAGE IS PERFECT.
I'M JUST TRYING TO GET
THE RIGHT HEAD THAT'S ALL.
Man: LEFT ARM FORWARD.
Jay: YOANNA, TRY AND HOLD THE
INTENSITY.
LIKE, JUST FOCUS IT.
YOANNA WAS
REALLY SCATTERED.
I FELT LIKE I
HAD TO STRUGGLE
TO GET HER TO FOCUS.
THERE YOU GO.
♪♪♪
Heather: THIS CAN HURT CATIE
DURING ELIMINATION 'CAUSE
IF SHE
DOESN'T GO THROUGH
WITH THIS, SHE MIGHT BE
THE NEXT TO GO.
Heather: OH, YEAH,
BABY.
Man: SHE'S GOT IT.
SHE'S GOT IT.
Richard: FACE ME.
YEAH, THAT'S GREAT!
Jay: GIVE ME THE
INTENSITY EYE,
BUT CLOSE YOUR MOUTH.
TALK TO ME
WITH YOUR EYES.
YEAH, NOW
CLOSE YOUR MOUTH.
Richard: HEATHER--
SHE HAD A TRICKY
TIME OUT THERE.
Jay: THAT'S GREAT.
Richard: THAT'S COOL,
COOL,
COOL, COOL,
COOL, COOL.
Heather: IT WAS NOT EASY,
AND IT DIDN'T FEEL VERY GOOD,
BUT AS LONG AS
THE PICTURES
TURN OUT GOOD,
THAT'S ALL
THAT COUNTS.
Man: GO AHEAD.
A LITTLE MORE.
Jenascia: WHOA. WHOA.
HEY, YOU
BE CAREFUL.
Jay: YEAH, THERE YOU GO.
UH-HUH.
CHIN UP A BIT.
THINK OF A HIGH
FASHION MODEL.
JENASCIA'S TOTALLY
UNAWARE OF HER BODY,
AND SHE DOESN'T SEEM
TO CARE ABOUT ANYTHING.
Jenascia: OH, GET ME OFF!
Jay: THE CHIN'S
A LITTLE TOO HIGH.
INTENSITY. THERE YOU GO.
Richard: OVER THERE.
THERE YOU GO. NICE.
Jay: JUST BE AWARE
OF YOUR FACE.
CAMILLE SEEMED TO GET WORSE THE
LONGER SHE WAS OUT THERE.
I DON'T THINK
IT WILL WORK.
CLOSE YOUR MOUTH.
Richard: UH-HUH.
THAT'S COOL.
THAT WAS COOL.
KICK THAT LEFT
HEEL OUT.
MERCEDES HAD A LOT OF ENERGY,
AND SHE HAD
A GOOD ATTITUDE.
Heather: IT IS EXTREMELY
HIGH.
I JUST DID NOT
LOOK DOWN.
JUST DON'T LOOK DOWN.
Jay: RIGHT NOW
WE'RE RUNNING
OUT OF LIGHT.
IF WE'RE GONNA DO IT,
WE GOTTA GO.
WE GOTTA GET YOU DRESSED
AND GET YOU UP THERE.
Xiomara: IF YOU WANT, DO YOU
WANT ME TO GO BEFORE YOU,
CATIE?
IF YOU'RE A
FRIEND OF ME,
I TAKE CARE OF YOU.
YOU TAKE CARE OF ME.
Catie: OH, MY GOD.
Xiomara: I AM PETRIFIED, BUT I
CAN'T SHOW IT
BECAUSE CATIE WAS ON SET.
Jay: SHE'S NOT NERVOUS
AT ALL.
Xiomara: IT'S ALL GOOD.
IT'S ALL GOOD.
Jay: YOU NOTICE HOW SHE DIDN'T
EVEN TIP EITHER WAY
AT ALL?
THAT'S WHY WE NEED
TO GET THE SHOT.
TRY TO PUT
THAT OTHER ARM BACK
WHEN YOU TWIST AS WELL.
Xiomara: HERE?
IS THAT GOOD?
Jay: THAT LOOKS GOOD.
YEAH.
Richard: CHIN UP.
THE RING IS OUT IN
FRONT OF YOU,
AND YOU'RE
REACHING FOR IT.
NOW BEND THAT ELBOW.
NO, NOT LIKE THAT.
XIOMARA--SHE HAD
A LITTLE BIT OF TROUBLE.
Xiomara: AGAIN?
Richard: YEAH.
Xiomara: I HAD NO
ATTENTION DURING MY SHOOT.
SOMETHING ELSE WAS
GOING ON,
AND I DIDN'T
GET ANY LOVE
BASICALLY, BUT
I UNDERSTAND THAT
JAY HAD TO TALK TO CATIE.
Jay: ALL WE NEED IS ONE.
EVEN IF YOU JUST
GIVE ME ONE
AND SAY, "I GOTTA GO BACK,"
I'LL TAKE THAT
ONE FROM YOU.
Jay: CATIE,
XIOMARA'S RIGHT HERE.
JUST LOOK AT XIOMARA,
OKAY?
LOOK AT XIOMARA.
LOOK AT ME.
Xiomara: IT'S OKAY, BABY.
IT'S CAKE.
IT'S CAKE,
BABY.
Jay: THAT'S
IT. THAT'S IT.
Catie: (crying)
>Jay: DO YOU WANT
TO COME UP, CATIE?
CATIE, DO YOU WANT
TO COME UP?
♪♪♪
Jay: DO YOU WANNA
COME UP, CATIE?
Catie: GIVE ME
A SECOND.
Jay: OKAY.
Catie: I'M THINKING,
"SUCK IT UP
AND GET IT OVER WITH.
YOU HAVE TO
DO THIS.
YOU'RE OUT HERE,
YOU MIGHT AS
WELL DO YOUR BEST ."
Jay: NO ONE ELSE
TALK, JUST ME.
OKAY, GREAT.
YEAH, SEXY.
CHIN UP JUST A BIT.
GIVE ME A
LITTLE MORE SEXY.
THERE YOU GO.
BEAUTIFUL, I LOVE IT.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT,
CATIE?
WE GOT IT.
YOU'RE DONE.
YOU ARE SO DONE.
(cheers and applause)
Richard: CATIE HUNG IN
THERE TILL THE VERY END--
A LITTLE TRAUMATIC
FOR HER,
BUT SHE GOT THE SHOT.
Catie: I FEEL RELIEVED THAT IT'S
OVER WITH,
AND I'M PROUD OF
MYSELF
THAT I DID IT.
IT SHOWS HOW MUCH
I WANT THIS.
Heather: THIS HAS MADE
ME REALIZE WE HAVE TO
BE THERE FOR EACH OTHER.
I'M VERY PROUD OF MYSELF,
AND I AM
EVEN MORE PROUD OF CATIE.
♪♪♪
Heather: TYRA MAIL!
TYRA MAIL!
Camille: "TOMORROW YOU WILL
MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY NINE OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON
WITH THE HOPE OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE
ELIMINATED ."
Shandi: EVERY
TIME WE GET
THAT PARTICULAR TYRA MAIL, A BIT
OF SADNESS GOES THROUGH ME,
YOU KNOW, 'CAUSE EVERY
TIME IT GETS HARDER.
♪♪♪
Heather: ELIMINATION
DAY IS TODAY.
I HAVE NO IDEA
WHO'S GOING TO GO.
I THINK IT'S GONNA
BE A COMPLETE SHOCK.
Catie: GOING INTO ELIMINATION
TODAY, I'M SCARED.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT MY
PICTURES WILL LOOK LIKE.
THEY'LL PROBABLY
LOOK LIKE CRAP.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY COULD
LOOK GOOD WITH ME BEING
IN THAT CONDITION
EMOTIONALLY.
♪♪♪
Tyra: HMM,
EVERYBODY LOOKS
LIKE NEW PEOPLE.
Janice: WOW!
WOW, WOW, WOW!
Tyra: IT'S TIME TO MAKE
OUR THIRD CUT TOWARDS
DETERMINING WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WE HAVE SOME
PRIZES-- A CONTRACT WITH IMG,
ONE OF THE TOP MANAGEMENT
COMPANIES IN THE WORLD,
A FASHION SPREAD
IN "JANE" MAGAZINE
AND A COSMETICS
CAMPAIGN WITH SEPHORA.
AND ALSO, WE HAVE OUR
PANEL OF JUDGES--
FIRST, BUT NOT LEAST,
IS MISS JANICE DICKINSON,
WHO IS THE FIRST SUPERMODEL
EVER IN THE WORLD IN EXISTENCE.
Janice: THAT'S IT.
THERE'S ONLY ME.
Tyra: ERIC NICHOLSON,
THE SENIOR FASHION EDITOR
OF "JANE" MAGAZINE,
NIGEL BARKER, WHO IS A
TOP FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
AND OF COURSE, THIS WEEK'S
GUEST JUDGE--JAY MANUEL,
MAKEUP
ARTIST EXTRAORDINAIRE.
THIS WEEK WE'RE GONNA PUT
YOU THROUGH A MAKEUP TEST,
AND JAY'S GONNA
EXPLAIN THAT.
Jay: YOU GIRLS ARE GONNA HAVE TO
RECREATE A SPECIFIC LOOK
REMINISCENT OF
A CERTAIN ERA.
WE HAVE '50s GLAMOUR,
'60s MOD,
'80s PUNK,
A GOTH LOOK AND
A FUTURISTIC LOOK.
THERE ARE NO
REFERENCE PHOTOS HERE, LADIES.
SO IT'S ALL UP TO HOW
YOU INTERPRET THESE LOOKS.
Tyra: EVERY GIRL
FOR HERSELF.
Jay: GO.
Tyra: GO, GO, GO,
GO, GO.
Heather: SORRY.
♪♪♪
Tyra: OKAY,
SHANDI,
YOU'RE FIRST.
Janice: SHANDI
IS SHANDIFIED.
Eric: GOTH!
Jay: SHE HAS THE ATTITUDE
TO MATCH WITH IT.
Tyra: THAT MAKEUP
LOOKS SO GREAT.
Janice: IT'S FIERCE.
Jay: YOU COMMITTED TO IT, AND
IT'S A GREAT JOB.
Tyra: SO YOU HAD A
PHOTO SHOOT WAY UP
IN THE SKY HIGH, LIKE SUPERMAN,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST PICTURE.
Janice: WOW.
Eric: THAT'S
"A CLOCKWORK ORANGE ."
Tyra: WORK IT.
Nigel: I THINK THE FOCUS IN YOUR
EYES IS REALLY GREAT.
Tyra: IT LOOKS LIKE IT CAN BE IN
A HIGH-FASHION MAGAZINE.
OKAY, YOANNA.
Nigel: I THINK YOUR MAKEUP
WORKS REALLY WELL
WITH YOUR HAIR.
Jay: IT'S '80s, BUT
IT'S NOT PUNK.
Janice: I WAS A MODEL
IN THE '80s.
I DON'T REMEMBER
MAKEUP LIKE THAT.
Tyra: YEAH, I DON'T
THINK IT'S PUNK.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Yoanna: OH, COOL.
Tyra: WOW, THAT'S PUNK.
Nigel: IT WORKS FOR ME IN
A COOL AND FUNKY WAY.
Tyra: COME ON UP HERE,
MERCEDES.
Janice: COME TO ME.
Tyra: WHAT'S YOUR CARD?
Janice: THAT WORKS.
Eric: THAT DOES WORK.
Tyra: I THINK IT'S REALLY COOL
AND DIFFERENT,
BUT I STILL WOULD'VE LIKED
TO SEE YOU PRETTIFY YOURSELF
JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE.
Janice: WHOA.
Tyra: WOW.
Eric: WOW.
Jay: YOU WERE GREAT.
Nigel: I LIKE YOUR BOOTY
IN THAT PICTURE.
LOOKS GOOD.
Tyra: COME ON
OUT, HEATHER.
Janice: HEY, NOW.
'80s PUNK.
I ADORE THE FUCHSIA.
Tyra: HERE'S YOUR
BEST SHOT.
Jay: I SPENT
A LOT OF TIME
TELLING YOU HOW
TO GIVE ME SOME INTENSITY.
YOU HAVE TO LEARN
HOW TO BECOME
MORE CONSCIOUS
OF YOUR FACE.
OF YOUR SELECTS,
I ONLY FOUND TWO SHOTS.
Nigel: YOU KNOW
WHAT?
YOU ONLY NEED ONE.
Tyra: THAT'S BULL
CRAP-- DOING 20 ROLLS
AND FINDING
ONE GOOD SHOT.
Eric: THERE SHOULD BE
SEVERAL GOOD PICTURES.
Tyra: AND ONE CRAZY ONE
THAT'S, LIKE, POW!
SARA.
I THINK YOUR
MAKEUP'S EXCELLENT.
I THINK ALL YOU
ALL WERE BORN
IN THE '80s,
SO YOU'RE, LIKE,
FEELIN' THAT ERA BECAUSE
THAT'S THE ERA
THAT YOU CAME
OUT YOUR MAMAS.
YOUR HAIR IS
SO '80s.
Janice: ANN-MARGRET.
WOW, THAT'S
SOME HAIR.
Tyra: HERE'S YOUR
BEST PICTURE.
Eric: WOW.
I LOVE THE
LINE THAT
YOU'RE MAKING
WITH YOUR BODY.
THIS LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE DANGLING
A HUNDRED FEET
ABOVE THE SKY.
YEAH, IT'S GREAT.
Tyra: JENASCIA.
OH, I LIKE THE
SIDE VIEW.
Janice: THIS IS
FUTURISTIC.
Jay: YOU
LOOK GORGEOUS.
Tyra: THAT'S ONE OF
MY FAVORITES SO FAR, ACTUALLY.
Eric: ONE-HANDED.
Tyra: I LOVE THE
INTENSITY.
Eric: SHE LOOKS
A FOOT TALLER.
Tyra: YEAH.
Eric: IT'S GREAT.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, CAMILLE.
Janice: THIS IS FUTURISTIC?
WOW, L.S.D. MAKEUP,
SORRY.
Nigel: IT'S
A LITTLE,
SORT OF, HALLOWEEN
FOR ME.
THERE'S SO MUCH GOING ON.
Jay: IF THE TWO
SYMBOLS ARE GONE,
THIS WOULD DEFINITELY
BE IN
A HIGH-END
FASHION EDITORIAL.
Tyra: THIS
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
IT REPRESENTS CAMILLE.
Jay: YOU'VE GOT SUCH
A STRONG PERSONALITY,
AND I KEPT TRYING TO GET YOU TO
GIVE ME, YOU KNOW, ENERGY.
BUT I NEVER GOT
ANY INTENSITY
OUT OF YOUR POSES.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, APRIL,
COME ON DOWN.
YOU ARE FUTURISTIC.
Eric: LOVE IT.
YOU'RE BARBARELLA.
Janice: THE WHITE JUST TAKES
AWAY FROM YOUR BEAUTY.
THIS MAKEUP, FOR ME, DOES
NOT ENHANCE YOUR BEAUTY.
Tyra: WHOA!
I LOVE THAT!
DAMN,
THAT'S DOPE.
Eric: WERE YOU
A DANCER?
April: JUST YOGA,
SIX YEARS.
Eric: OKAY.
Janice: IT SHOWS.
IT'S REALLY GOOD.
Jay: WE HAD SO MANY SHOTS, IT
WAS VERY HARD TO CHOOSE,
WHICH IS
A GOOD THING.
Tyra: THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKIN' ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT, XIOMARA.
Nigel: XIOMARA,
YOU LOOK LIKE
A MIME
ACT, SLIGHTLY.
Xiomara: I'M GOTH, AND THEY
DON'T REALLY TALK MUCH.
I WENT TO SCHOOL
WITH A LOT OF THEM.
Jay: BUT THIS IS FASHION
GOTH, NOT THE KIDS
YOU WENT TO
SCHOOL WITH.
Tyra: THIS CHOICE SHOULD'VE
HAD NO BOUNDARIES.
TAKE IT ALL THE WAY.
Janice: HAVE MERCY ON
MY SOUL, CHILD.
Jay: THIS IS AS CLOSED AS
I FOUND YOUR MOUTH.
Eric: THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
JUST ISN'T CONNECTING.
IT JUST LOOKS SLOPPY.
Xiomara: I DIDN'T HARDLY
HAVE MUCH DIRECTION,
IN ALL DUE HONESTY
AND FAIRNESS TO YOU,
BECAUSE HE WAS
COMFORTING CATIE.
I WAS UP THERE BY MYSELF.
Eric: THEN YOU SPEAK UP.
YOU SAY, "HEY WHAT
ABOUT ME? "
Tyra: YEAH.
I KNOW IF YOU TOLD JAY,
"I NEED YOU RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT CAN CHANGE MY LIFE,
AND YOU NOT
DIRECTING ME
RIGHT NOW AND
BEING HERE
FOR EVERY
SINGLE FRAME CAN
MAKE ME POSSIBLY BE ELIMINATED."
I BET CATIE'S PICTURE'S GONNA
BE BETTER THAN YOURS.
'CAUSE CATIE WAS
THINKIN' ABOUT HERSELF,
AND YOU'RE
THINKIN' ABOUT CATIE.
CATIE.
Catie: I HAVE A LITTLE
WORD TO SAY.
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
YOU REALIZE, YES, JAY WAS
SITTING NEXT TO ME
FOR MOST OF THE
PART.
THE ENTIRE TIME,
HE NEVER SAID A WORD TO ME.
HE WAS DIRECTING
XIOMARA.
Xiomara: HE WAS
DIRECTING ME,
BUT HE WAS
ALSO COMFORTING YOU AS WELL.
IT WAS REALLY
CONFUSING.
IT WAS REALLY WEIRD.
THE ENERGY-- AND I WAS
COMFORTING YOU
WHEN YOU WERE
GOING UP, TOO,
AND YOU KNOW THAT.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT I
SAID TO YOU.
Janice: BOARDING SCHOOL.
BOARDING SCHOOL.
I DON'T CARE WHAT
YOU GUYS DID ON THE SET.
LET'S SEE THE
PICTURE, PLEASE.
WE NEED TO JUDGE
THE PHOTOGRAPH.
OH.
Tyra: IT'S KIND
OF FIERCE.
Jay: IT'S--YEAH.
Janice: IT'S MUCH
BETTER THAN THE OTHER.
IN FACT, IT'S QUITE
FABULOUS.
Tyra: YEAH.
Jay: AS SOON AS
YOU GAVE ME
THIS PHOTOGRAPH,
I TOOK YOU OFF.
AND LOOK, WE GOT
A GREAT SHOT.
SHE ONLY
SHOT 12 FRAMES.
Tyra: IT'S ONE OF THE
STRONGEST PICTURES.
Nigel: THIS WORKS.
Tyra: WELL,
NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES
TO DELIBERATE.
SEE YOU IN A BIT.
Janice: OH, MY GOD.
DRAMA,
DRAMA.
Catie: CAN I
GET SOME WATER?
Heather: WE NEED A FAN
OR SOMETHING.
Camille: COME OUT
IN THE FRESH AIR.
Heather: YOU NEED
A FAN OR SOMETHING?
Yoanna: AFTER THE JUDGING,
CATIE JUST KIND OF GOT
WEAK AND FAINT.
Sara: THERE WAS THIS BIG
PRODUCTION WITH HER
GETTING
FANNED AND WATER,
AND I THOUGHT IT
WAS HILARIOUS.
Xiomara: AFTER THE WHOLE
ATTITUDE DEAL, LIKE,
"LET ME TELL
YOU SOMETHING,
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH,
BLAH, BLAH, "
AND THEN WE'RE
GONNA WALK OUT
AND PASS OUT.
PICK A CHARACTER--
EITHER YOU'RE THE SCARED
CRAPLESS GIRL,
OR YOU ARE THIS
ATTITUDE-HAVING DIVA,
BUT DON'T TRY TO
BE BOTH.
IT JUST DOESN'T WORK.
CATIE DID NOT
HAVE TO GO THERE
TRYING TO SELL ME OUT.
I'M DEFINITELY
GONNA GO HOME TODAY.
Tyra: WE'VE
SEEN EVERYBODY,
AND NOW IT'S TIME
TO DELIBERATE.
Janice: CATIE'S
HAVING MELTDOWNS
ON EVERY GIVEN OPPORTUNITY.
AND YOU CAN'T JUST
MELT DOWN
AT THE DROP OF A HAT.
CATIE'S OUT.
Jay: XIOMARA.
Janice: AH, SEE
YA LATER.
Jay: I AGREE
WITH YOU, JANICE.
Tyra: THIS PICTURE IS THE
WEAKEST OF THE WHOLE BUNCH.
SHE LOOKS LIKE SHE'S
NOT READY.
SHE LOOKS EXTREMELY
UNCOMFORTABLE.
Janice: MERCEDES HAS REALLY
SHOWN INCREDIBLE GROWTH.
I LOVE THIS GIRL.
Jay: I LOVE SHANDI'S
TRANSFORMATION.
Janice: I THINK THAT THIS GIRL
HAD IT IN HER ALL ALONG.
Eric: SHE STILL SEEMS
A LITTLE BIT MEEK
WHEN SHE'S INTERACTING
WITH THE PANEL.
I'D LIKE TO SEE A
LITTLE BIT MORE CONFIDENCE.
Tyra: CAMILLE.
THIS PICTURE
LOOKS LIKE
HER VERY
FIRST PHOTO SHOOT
THAT SHE'S EVER DONE.
Jay: YOANNA'S
ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
Tyra: SHE LOOKS
VERY CONFIDENT.
Nigel: YOANNA HAS
A LOVELY FACE.
I THINK SHE NEEDS TO
DEFINITELY WORK ON HER BODY.
Tyra: SARA'S PICTURE IS
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS,
BUT HER PERSONALITY,
IT'S JUST
KINDA LIKE
A GIRL, YOU KNOW,
"LIKE WHAT'S UP, GIRL?"
APRIL.
Janice: THIS GIRL
IS MY FAVORITE.
Jay: APRIL SEEMS
TOO CLINICAL.
Tyra: I WOULD LOVE TO SEE A MORE
ROMANTIC SIDE OF HER.
Jay: I HAD TO FIGHT WITH HEATHER
ON THIS SHOOT,
JUST TO GET HER FACIAL
EXPRESSION
TO LOOK SOMEWHAT
LIKE A MODEL.
HEATHER'S OUT.
Janice: I SAY HEATHER'S IN.
Tyra: JENASCIA.
Janice: YOU WANT
MY OPINION?
SHE'S TOO SHORT.
Eric: I DISAGREE.
OTHER MODELS, LIKE KATE MOSS,
SET THE STANDARD.
Nigel: SHE'S NOT KATE MOSS.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT,
YOU ALL.
WE HAVE REACHED OUR
DIFFICULT DECISION.
Tyra: TEN BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE NINE
PHOTOS IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE NINE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE NINE OF YOU THAT
WILL CONTINUE ON THE
JOURNEY TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
SHANDI.
CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE
RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
APRIL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOANNA, YOU'RE STILL IN THE
RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
Yoanna: THANK YOU.
Tyra: YOU'RE WELCOME.
MERCEDES.
Mercedes: THANK YOU.
Tyra: YOU'RE WELCOME.
SARA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
CAMILLE, YOU'RE STILL IN THE
RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
JENASCIA.
Jenascia: THANKS.
Tyra: YOU'RE WELCOME.
Tyra: CATIE.
Tyra: CATIE,
WE ALL HAVE FEARS,
BUT YOU CANNOT
LET YOUR FEARS
WRECK YOUR FUTURE.
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
Catie: THANK YOU.
Tyra: WILL XIOMARA AND HEATHER
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
Tyra: HEATHER,
THE JUDGES HAVE CONTINUED
TO LOOK AT
YOUR PICTURES,
AND SOMETIMES WE THINK YOU
MAY LOOK A LITTLE TOO TEEN.
SOME FEEL LIKE IT MIGHT
BE JUST A BABYNESS.
WE'RE NOT SURE IF
IT HAS TO DO
WITH YOU
BEING 18 YEARS OLD
OR IF THAT'S JUST
YOUR LOOK.
XIOMARA, ONE THING THAT
THE JUDGES DON'T UNDERSTAND
IS HOW YOU COULD LET THE
ATTENTION THAT ANOTHER GIRL
IS GETTING
RUIN YOUR CHANCES
AT WINNING THIS
COMPETITION.
WE THINK THIS WAS
YOUR WEAKEST
WEEK SINCE
YOU'VE BEEN HERE.
WHOEVER'S NAME I
DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY GO
BACK TO THE LOFT
AND PACK YOUR
BELONGINGS AND LEAVE.
Tyra: XIOMARA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Xiomara: (cries)
Tyra: YOU'RE GONNA
MAKE ME CRY, TOO.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
Xiomara: THANK YOU.
♪♪♪
Heather: I AM
JUST STUNNED, SHOCKED.
I KNOW THAT
I'M PRETTIER
THAN A LOT
OF THOSE GIRLS
STANDING UP THERE.
SO I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE TRYING,
AND I'M NOT GONNA LET
THIS DRAG ME DOWN.
SOMEONE ELSE
WILL LIKE ME.
YOU KNOW,
ONE MAN'S TRASH
IS ANOTHER MAN'S TREASURE.
OBVIOUSLY,
I'M TRASH HERE,
AND I'LL BE
A TREASURE SOMEWHERE ELSE.
♪♪♪
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
HERE'S WHAT'S COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
A SURPRISE VISITOR
SHAKES THINGS UP.
Yoanna: OUR GUEST IS LAST
YEAR'S WINNER--ADRIANNE.
Tyra: AND CATIE'S
HAD ENOUGH.
Catie: THE PAST THREE DAYS
HAVE BEEN THE WORST DAYS
OF MY LIFE.
I REALLY JUST WANT
TO GO HOME.
Tyra: WHILE
MERCEDES COPES
WITH A SERIOUS ILLNESS.
Mercedes: THERE'S SO MUCH
COMING OUT, AND I'M SCARED.